u.s democrats have officially nominated
former vice president joe biden as their
party's candidate
to challenge president donald trump in
the november election
this year the convention has gone online
as social distancing makes the
old style rallies impossible biden's
supporters endorsed him largely as the
man who can unite a divided america
and they include some heavyweights from
the rival party
the democratic party convention four
years ago
and this is now the convention center in
milwaukee is little more than a facility
receiving and pumping out video content
the democrats have now formally named
joe biden
as their presidential candidate the
votes came in remotely
california home to our next vice
president kamala harris
cast 231 votes for bernie sanders
and 263 votes for our next president joe
biden
the online celebrations had a message
while its members were social distancing
the democratic party was very much
united
biden's nomination was accompanied by a
slew of endorsements
his wife jill was one of many to
emphasize biden's ability to unite the
country
after president donald trump's turbulent
tenure
we just need leadership worthy of our
nation
worthy of you honest leadership to bring
us back together
to recover from this pandemic and
prepare for whatever else is next
leadership to re-imagine what our nation
will be
that's joe how did donald trump former
president bill clinton
led the charge attacking the incumbent
well we are
at a time like this the oval office
should be a command center
instead it's a storm center there's only
chaos
just one thing never changes his
determination to deny responsibility
and shift the blame former secretary
of state colin powell became a further
prominent republican
to throw his weight behind biden at the
convention
he will restore america's leadership in
the world and restore the alliances we
need
to address the dangers that threaten our
nation from climate change to nuclear
proliferation
trump for his part was trying to steal
the limelight
as the democrats embraced diversity and
inclusiveness
the president was in the border state of
arizona
and he was railing against immigration
the biden plan
would unleash a flood of illegal
immigration like the world has never
seen it's crazy
biden's plan is the most radical extreme
reckless dangerous and deadly
immigration plan
ever put forward by a major party
candidate
the democrats are continuing to cast
trump as a divisive figure
but the president is sticking to his
tried and true playbook
regardless of what the polls are saying
dw's peter grillad has been following
the convention force he's with us in our
studio
hi peter so joe biden is now officially
the democratic nominee what stood out to
you after two days of this convention
well it seems the democratic party has
finally settled
on a strategy to beat donald trump at
least what they think will be donald
trump
the main thing is one that's not
entirely unlike the one that barack
obama
um ran on which was you know there's not
a red america is not a blue america
there's a united states of america that
message of unity is
absolutely central to the message
that the democratic party has been
really trying to hammer home over the
past couple of days we've seen
you know video after video testimony
after testimony really showing
how broad um you know
the big tent that the democratic party
is trying to paint itself as
that there's more that unites americans
that device him that's a very central
message that i think a lot of people are
yearning for at the moment in the united
states
the second part is obviously going after
trump
painting him as unfit for office uh
we've had
several republicans testifying to that
in in
the course of the past two days
and also as someone who doesn't really
care about anyone but himself you know
we're going through this pandemic and
and someone who has not taken that
seriously who's not shown himself as
being able to relate to the pain that a
lot of people are going through
and that leaves it with point three
which is biden as the emphasizer in
chief
the man who understands struggle who
understands pain
someone who can relate and i think that
combination is what they're
really trying to to really push
coming out of this convention coming
back to that message of unity
is it working because we know there were
real rifts that opened up in the
democratic party that we really saw come
out especially in the primaries
yeah i mean in terms of messaging
they've done a very good job but we
are actually still we are seeing some of
those rifts
still um you know there are signs of
tension within the party we have kind of
this this
old guard versus new guard you so saw
someone like bill clinton the former
president
who got a five-minute speaking slot now
he's not very popular among young voters
anymore progressive voters who see him
as kind of a disgraced
president who gutted welfare uh
who represent everything that the metoo
era has been kind of speaking out
against or the
metoo movement has been speaking out
against uh with his affair with monica
lewinsky
and at the same time you had someone
like alexandria ocasio-cortez
aoc the kind of the firebrand the star
of the progressive
left who got 90 seconds speaking slot
so i think that really speaks to this
tough balancing act that biden is also
facing um going out of this convention
right he needs to win over voters from
maybe the broadest political spectrum
that the democratic party has ever had
to um
you know cater to um from progressive
left wings to
to even disenchanted republicans so it's
a very tough balancing act
and just quickly and those disenchanted
republicans because we saw some of those
speakers as well so how are the dems
really trying to distinguish themselves
from the republican party right now
well i think that is one of the main
points that they are trying to
exactly say that they are the party of
inclusivity a party where everyone
is welcome whether actually you're
republican
but or or a democrat as long as you're
not
you know trump all right our reporter
peter ladau looking at the convention
for us thank you so much for bringing us
that